this is 8 news now live at 11 live
local now
[Applause]
the golden knights getting off to a
great start in the race for the stanley
cup thanks for joining us at 11 i'm
denise feltes and i'm brian loftis the
montreal canadiens skating into the
fortress tonight but they could not stop
the night sports director chris matthews
starts out our 8 news now team coverage
with some of the highlights yeah i'll
tell you what guys really vegas looked
like a much better team the knights have
only beaten montreal though once in
their short history
that was way back in february of 2018
this is a different team
a deeper bigger faster team montreal
those skates onto the ice
looking like a team that had won seven
games in a row they were red hot
but they're facing the best in the west
vegas just won
four in a row over the avalanche golden
knights are deep big fast and shea
theodore lights the lamp first vegas is
on the board
that's the first lead montreal has
surrendered in eight games now the
knights would jump out to a two-only
nice pass alec martinez buries the puck
vegas rolling along but then montreal
gets into it one goal game here when
matthias yanmark with less than a minute
later after that montreal goal
it kind of seemed to deflate the
canadians there vegas adds a nick hold
goal here
in the third and they win it four to one
fleury who grew up a habs fan
beats his childhood team with 28 saves
in his 90th
career play-off win now over reaction
from the golden knights later in sports
but those medieval maniacs
boy they are loving life kevin martin
now witnessed the whole thing first hand
the thrill of victory tonight let's head
out to t-mobile arena where the knights
lead that best of seven series now
one zip hey kevin
well hey chris you know although the
golden knights came into tonight's game
one matchup against montreal as the
heavy favorites
there was still a lot of unknowns
surrounding the fortress because
the last time these two teams met on the
ice was january of 2020 so as you can
imagine
after the game the medieval maniacs were
thrilled to pick up the game one win
here tonight at the fortress
super excited gold knights are going to
take it i have a feeling
we're gonna take the stanley cup it's
it's on i love the golden knights
we're gonna dominate the series i think
i promise you one thing las vegas you're
gonna have your first stanley cup
trophy we're going to be here in las
vegas
[Applause]
well we can't get ahead of ourselves we
still have three more wins to punch our
ticket to the final and of course four
more wins to claim that stanley cup but
all eyes are on vegas right now as they
pick up the huge
game one 4-1 victory over the montreal
canadians reporting live at t-mobile
arena kevin martin 8 sports now